back by popular man we have a
Valentine's Day themed round of race my
case God where people like and race my
case they were loving it we got a lot of
submissions I ended up doing these
because I wanted Valentine's related
ones but people loved it
evidently I maybe I shouldn't even
address this but there's some rude dude
out there and there people are saying we
I know root dude I know Rudy do that
just show but I read his book actually
his book is he dude have you ever done
the show on shave 4 or 5 I never done I
did it when I was doing promotional for
a Showtime he's a great dude people are
saying we jacked the show I had no idea
it was it was a one of our listener
submissions and got our raised my case
at Brian's legit
I'll check him with him and ask him I
don't feel like we did I know we didn't
jacket yeah yeah for sure I had a little
accident also I don't think he's the
only one where people you gotta guess
who's doing the crime yeah so guys so
first we gonna read a case and we have
to each put in who we feel like what
culture ethnicity did the crime so
specific or as on specific as we need to
yeah or country if you can't just pick
up one race here we go man gets prison
for Valentine's Day robbery of bank
where girlfriend worked blank who needed
money to buy his girlfriend an
engagement ring is now headed a federal
prison for help carrying out a
Valentine's Day robbery outside the bank
where she worked
he's been sentenced to six and a half
years it took put he's held up 26
thousand dollars from a bradford
national bank that they were stocking
outside an ATM he drove away in his 2008
mustang mexican mustang passionate
latino loves his woman can you say he
must thank you - word must do know what
it feels like it boost anga elmo's Tanya
give me the details again I didn't hear
it so he was he robbed the bank where
his girlfriend works for money to buy
her an engagement ring us is why he'd do
it all day when I grew up in a Ford my
that's my wife oh yeah so wait I think
they were in on it I think the chick was
probably in on it and it sounds like it
was a white guy to me yeah you know I'm
saying why can the I'm gonna say like
Oklahoma Texas area but here's the thing
though if you tell somebody you tell
your girl if you're a if you're a white
guy you tell your girl okay I'm gonna
come in here I'm gonna rob the bank you
need to beat you're gonna be there like
I'm just trying to think whose gonna go
along with that if you say that to me
dumbass the girl says she didn't know
and she was cleared of all charges
everything had to well here this might
uh shed some light he was dropped off at
a neighboring City and took a greyhound
back to his girlfriend's to comfort her
and everybody's on there I feel like but
not Asian so I'm gonna say it's not
Asian because you it's white black or
Mexican on greyhound do it so this is
this is why it all day I'd say why y'all
got white Latino you know I'm gonna go
I'll go black I'm white Oklahoma white
for sure ramsey [ __ ]
was Lebanese dating a white girl that
did not specify but most likely Lebanon
I know you don't make sense yeah that
was your neck it just clicked and
Craig's like the Lebanese are into that
bank robbery kind of the old Wild
Western type of stuff you know that's
also the plot from Ben Affleck's movie
the town is it yes great movie zero zero
zero zero no one scored next one is
Jesus Christ dude Valentine's Day lovers
were caught on closed-caption TV as they
robbed a til from a jewelry store a pair
of lovestruck
lovestruck teens shared this romantic
moment in front of a TV that they did
not know is recording they ended up
stealing $275 and left cameras laptops
and smartphones that they could have
stole so was a lover's quarrel this is a
Romeo and Juliet type of thing they
wanted the jewelry it's Valentine they
wanted the jewelry Oh
not a terrible idea I'm going white I'm
going black black I'm gonna go black -
you said they left cell phones and
laptops everything valuable yeah black
dude oh [ __ ] we love now they don't
definitely black it was a 19 year old
lay you an 18 year old jingchou or
Chinese what was the first name lay you
le I lay Lou is a black guys right
that's the boy lay Lulu Johnson Jane Chu
sounds like a noose Copenhagen Skol he's
got that Jiang Jiang yeah we're so off
no one's even close late Liu so anybody
who scores here takes it home we got our
last one right
a man stole roses from all DS grocery
store that were 1999 for his girlfriend
for Valentine's Day well wasted white
boy a man stole roses that were worth
$19.99 from an all DS grocery store for
Valentine's Day for his girlfriend i'ma
switch it up and say Pakistani Wow you
gonna pieced and all I'm saying what
I'll do all these is prominently usually
a white type of environment in there
it's a good Midwestern grocery store I'm
gonna say white yeah I'm saying white -
sprite happen at maybe Albertsons or
King Soopers this is a white boy all day
to do a white boy with drunk drunk with
love you can do some crazy [ __ ] what
what Craig say white white he was
Pakistani
my heart like that girl broke my heart
when I gave her that album that's why
some people haven't gotten over
something
[Music]